the fear of eviction is going to become
a reality for thousands
as the cdc eviction moratorium comes to
an end next month
tonight our local leaders want to help
joe muller
joins us live with information on the
new program that can help keep people
in their homes joe well christian the
nevada eviction moratorium ends
later this month and the cdc one ends
next month and county leaders
expect a flood of eviction so today they
went over the process that could help
many people who are facing eviction if
you get a notice you are being told to
file a response to the justice court
labeled on your notice
tenants are encouraged to request
mediation they say by
filing a response it will trigger a
review by the county a case worker will
then reach out and give you
guides you through the chat rental
assistance application
and help with resources assistant county
manager kevin schiller
says multiple agencies and departments
are coming together for this
and with that moratorium ending and as
we move forward
this collaboration has not existed in
the history of the state
so what this will allow for is a
connection point between mediators
the chap rental assistance program and
clark county
in conjunction with the courts
about 9 000 people are currently waiting
for their chap application to be looked
at the county says they are
bringing on more workers to address that
an eligible household the four can make
up to 60 thousand dollars to be
eligible for chap program they say there
is still 160 million dollars worth of
assistance left to disperse they
estimate
that this could still help another 40
000 households now we have talked to
several people who are waiting for their
application and others say they are also
worried about how long the process could
take the county did say today they are
working to speed that
process up reporting live here near d.i
joe muller 8 news